taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds joe in
the universe
of pickles and olives
hey everyone welcome to taste buds
podcast i'm sal
and i'm sal
and today we have for you pickles and
olives and i will tell you something
polarizing foods to both of them
i'm curious about something people love
i hate picks people love i hate olives
i'm curious about something because we
started
we launched this poll a while ago and
then we got really sidetracked with
something before we started recalling so
we're already up to fourteen thousand
votes
fourteen thousand one hundred fifty
which is more than we had like all that
stuff yeah so this is a much more
insightful debate than i thought it was
gonna be well let me also start with
something else because if you watched
last week's episode
you know that there was a wager placed
for 20 on whether i referenced heineken
when i was talking about loggers that i
liked yes and and again pimp do whatever
editing magic you want to do here but
joe
was firm in his resolve that i said the
word heineken and he was almost arrogant
and i said to him i know what i said and
i didn't say we made it 20 american
wager yeah
and uh i said pim can have my winnings
if i win and i want you to know we went
back and we looked at the tape which you
probably already did but just rewinding
on the youtube
i didn't say heineken at all
i didn't say heineken he said tall
he said 20 bucks
jackson he said highlight
i'll take it as a joey rose's uh gift
card okay
nice oh you get out and you make money
out of that so it cost me nothing now
no a high life he said hi life but he
said it a little half-assed and i
thought he said heineken
i heard the high i thought he said
let me tell you if this was a press
conference and that quote hit the papers
you would be reamed in the papers
i heard hi and i thought you said
heineken it wasn't like you didn't say
anything anywhere near it i know but i
heard you consider that because when i
told you no no no i'll tell you the
beers i said i said i said hi life
i said rolling rock i said pabst i said
bud light i said course and you heard me
even reiterate to you all of those and
not in that moment did you say oh maybe
i'm confusing high life behind again why
give it to you
i get that right now you're out of 20
spot
i'm not really i'm at a couple slices of
mortadella
a few rolls all right well pimp enjoy
your sandwiches he'll enjoy him just
fine because the best sandwiches in new
york city
all right i don't disagree well it's a
mighty nice have you ever stopped by for
one
i'm sorry i know you've been so busy all
summer i'm sorry i'm not perusing that
area at lunch if i am i'll come by maybe
a special trip for a friend
you ever think of that
i mean yeah it's
like 25 in tolls 40 in parking two hours
in commuting but i'll do that and come
in and have one sandwich it's fine
you'll ask me to do that to come dick
around with you on your couch on a
friday night yeah but that's me and you
quality time
what
no but i you know i would love to come
in and have sandwiches if i lived near
there i would be having them all the
time where is the shop joe maybe give a
plug it's at the stand in new york city
you know a place that sal never goes to
i'm there in the evening time but they
put your roses away yeah yeah yeah yeah
they put it away i get it yeah your
sandwiches are nice
it's only been open since november of
2020. oh dude
2019 full pandemic 2019.
let me let me just
let me trek to another borough
joey rose's pop-up
12 to 4 p.m wednesday to friday at the
stand in new york city and i want to
thank
all the people an investor in your new
business
what are you going to let me know on
that by the way i told you when you gave
it to me i said yeah whatever it is
i kind of have a look but i can't
imagine i'm not going to just i'm not
going to do it is this a verbal is this
a verbal contract you wait let's just
take it down a notch for a second drop
my mic out no
no yeah yeah babe if you whatever you
need i got you all right listen take 20
out of the check give that to pimp
[Laughter]
uh
here's the thing that joey rose's only
at the stand in new york city by the way
real quick because i didn't plug in the
last one and i got to pick it you got to
pick that up but uh i got a tour to plug
the guys and i have announced a tour we
got 45 cities with more to be announced
um it's a big tour man it's an arena
tour and we're super excited for it
it'll be the first time on tour in over
two years we're riding the show now
tickets are completely on sale right now
already as we speak if you don't see
your city
it'd probably be added
thetenderloins.com tour
for the tickets and i'm going to be
announcing a solo tour soon that's cool
that'd be salvocano comedy.com go on
there and check it out for now but the
dates will be announced big stuff well
the dates are i mean those other ones
aren't announced yet
i just want to let you know to look out
for me because it's been a long while
and i'm planning the tour now and it's
going to be a long tour and it's going
to be hard to do it is long but i'm
ready i'm ready to come to about 100
cities in the next year that's heavy but
you guys travel in style it won't be too
bad right
oh yeah i travel in in in travel and
gucci flip-flops no but i mean like
you're you get a tour bus and right bus
tour we do when we do bus tours uh
this will mostly be weekends but on long
on long weekends we're gonna get a bus
and stuff like that so a lot of this
will be flying yeah oh wow okay
and and then maybe busting between
cities but flying in and flying out at
the minimum new new variants
hey have fun out there listen
[Laughter]
stay home folks
[Laughter]
no it's gonna be great you guys are
gonna have fun how long does it take you
to write the show
uh we've been we've been messing with it
during pandemic but now we're finally
gonna do about
20 20 warm-up shows in the next two
months oh wow jesus and try to figure it
out
it's kind of wild though it's not like
we it's not like how we write materials
so
it's
it's different kind of this queue sits
on a whoopee cushion
wow reducing it to that while asking me
for an investment
wow
it's too funny stop it it's a too funny
of a joke
you know i love you guys it's you're
hilarious i can't always the joke is
just makes me laugh i tell everyone
whoever tries to make a joke about this
show he's just like oh you pull your
pants down whoopee cushion it's not that
but
you know whatever lets you put your head
on your pillow at night
you know
no worries oh listen man
i live a lonely life and all i really
have is
my razor sharp uh venomous wits and uh
razor razor sharp
i'm i i feel better about myself but
being mean to others there i said it
okay
no one you're not admitting anything to
anyone
you are you are you are the human
version of a grouch form yeah you are
oscar the grouch as a man absolutely i
swear to god if he had a wish and he was
like i wish i was a real boy
how are your spectacles
absolutely you came right out of a tin
trash it's only a matter it's only a
matter of time for me
the business is going to catch up to me
you are awesome
yeah well it's like you are why are you
so
why why are you so enamored by this
realization i know you're grouchy but i
never liken you to the muppet i kind of
look like him and i i contain a similar
demeanor but listen it's only a matter
of time before the business catches
please please let me film this as a skit
you coming out of a trash can
you should like you like over like
there'll be two people having a
conversation you should just pop out of
the goddamn can and just start railing
on them like
i'll tell you i'm gonna be about i'm
gonna be about
60 years old
yeah
[Music]
sneak up on people on the street
just burst out and just start railing on
them and complaining about [ __ ]
oh my god dude oh god if even at the
least for halloween you gotta be asking
the grouch i feel like it's two on the
nose i'll do this the street sketch i
like i like the street you just i just
feel like hear the banging of the of the
top as it comes off yeah i got the
rattling
even that i'm mad about i'm like ow
yeah
the whole thing i'm telling you man i'm
telling you i'm when i hit about 62
years old in this business
i'm going to come into my own i'm
telling you they're going to come to me
like they did larry david and they're
going to be like you you should be on a
tv show where we just let you complain
about everything you
just just been attacked
human like if we just put green paint on
your face and arms right and you just go
around just railing on people right just
oh i it's for some reason the simplicity
of that is so funny to me
it is funny
it's funny the popping out of the can is
funny it's so funny right like you're
just like
like you just
well it's funny just scare this
people
people popping out of things is very
funny yeah like the an intro of like
like the superhero origin stories or
like
you know like how you became
like the human form of him or something
you really love this idea don't you
really something about us got me
[Laughter]
speaking of green
oh yeah
olives and pickles babes it's the great
green gauntlet throw down today between
the pickles and the olives uh i would
like to begin by saying i am team pickle
salads team olive you kicked off the
last argument
uh which was uh beer versus wine uh
which i won by a lot uh but i would like
to kick off this argument now okay
and say i am a fan of the olive
i love an olive bar in a supermarket i
love a supermarket it takes an extra
step to put in an olive bar it's very
fun picking up that plastic container
filling it up with the wrinkled black
olives
the green pimento
uh the large greek the kamala clematis
kalamata kalamat excuse me harris
[Laughter]
i love it i love an olive bar maybe even
steal a few pickled mushrooms and some
roasted red peppers while you're there
i love an olive bar you bring it home
you spill it out on a on a tray with
some
sharp crumbly provolone cheese or god
i'm getting hungry or parmesan some
beautiful prosciutto that's like pootery
bought a little bit of fruit a little
bit of yeah meat some cheese
it's quite a wonderful wonderful thing
in that whole world it's a champion of
that one i love olives i put olives in
my salad a lot of the time i love olives
but where do you get off
thinking that they can go against
the pickle
america got its name from a pickle
merchant that is true it is on the
screen italian explorer amerigo vespucci
was a ship chandler supplying merchants
and sailors with supplies for their
voyages including preserved meats and
vegetables his nickname the pickle
merchant likely arose from his former
trade although writer wealth ralph waldo
emerson
derisively referred to vespucci bespucci
excuse me as a pickled dealer
i'm sorry where does it where does the
name how does america get its name
amerigo do you see his first name
that can't be real that's real that's
100 real america is named after
americova's future
italian people merchants i just didn't
know he was a pickle merch until now
sal
pickles what
how have i been alive on this earth
since 1976
and i don't know that the united states
of america is actually the united states
of americo vespucci pickle merchant
italian pickle merchant
you learn something new every day but
this is what i'm talking about sal how
are you attempting to take on the pickle
right now it is on the plate
of every sandwich ever ordered in every
deli
americans consume nine pounds of pickles
per person every year the most popular
type remains kosher dill thanks to large
numbers of eastern european jews who
immigrate to the united states and new
york in the late 19th century it is
garnishing every single sandwich you've
ever received it has become a flavor of
chip because chips in a pickle are so
popular sandwiches
a topping on sandwiches on burgers
a constant is the pickle and like i said
i love it i love it when a supermarket
usually a wegmans type of place has a
olive bar
but i'll tell you what a supermarket
never doesn't have
a variety of pickles not just in
the
pickle aisle but also the special ones
that you have to keep cold
and a pickle bucket at the deli where
you can buy the large pickles
by themselves and the bags and stuff
i mean a pickle looks like a diseased
animal phallus
hasn't stopped it's got lumps
i mean let's call the pickle what it is
it's a cuke
is it not
a pizza cucumber
cucumber sucks so hard
that people were like can we do
something with this
throw it in that bucket for a long time
with all these juices and just see if it
because all it is is a super cuke
a pickle is a super cucumber and a
cucumber is just
i mean a cucumber is
light and refreshing but nobody nobody
nobody's battling for a cucumber i'll
tell you this cucumber is a forgettable
fruit uh there's a fruit or vegetable i
don't know
pic crunchy celery salt or sweet pickles
all start the same way as cucumbers
right okay
nobody's going to bat for the cucumber
are you nuts
are you nuts did you ever have an asian
cucumber cucumber
cucumbers got eliminated
if cucumbers got eviscerated eliminated
from our lives nobody would miss an
episode of seinfeld where george
costanza brought outside food into the
diner they frequented every episode was
cucumber because he needed it in his
salad
only outside food ever on on seinfeld
let me tell you this let me tell you
this
let me tell you this must be the olive
it beats the olive i'll give you another
hit i'll give you another hit why beat
the pickle beats the other i'll give it
a great there's some there's great stuff
for both of these we're going to read it
i'll give you another thing though
you're going to hate on the cucumber
and the pickle for being the beautiful
uh worm into butterfly equation that
that is that it's two beings one that
becomes more beautiful a version of the
last jar of an olive before the olive
process happens no
you haven't because it's inedible it's
inedible but a cucumber is edible it's
as a matter of fact that's my point it's
as popular as a pickle that's my my
point not good though my point is is you
have one food that becomes an even
better food when it turns into the
pickle and olive is only an olive after
the olive process can i live off the
tree forget it okay i love i love a bare
bottom and i love bare bottom clothing
share it on the bottom clothing will
cover up your bare bottom this is a
go-to for guys looking to update the
wardrobe with high quality made to last
threads without dishing out a small
fortune those things that they wrote for
us to say are true that is i will tell
you that no because they sent us some
clothes i've been wearing them they are
high quality yes they aren't expensive
but they are a lot of really good cuts
and they are good quality so if you're
looking to update your wardrobe but you
don't have do you know when i used to
remember how we used to shop we used to
go like
literally walk through a mall and then
go
and just trying on everything over and
over again carrying bags going to the
next thing like oh i need this i need
that you could literally go onto bare
bottoms website just just siphon right
through it and just check what you need
get everything delivered try it on at
home if it doesn't work out you could
send it back it's in by the way best
deal and by the way don't just believe
us there's ten thousand five star
reviews so you know they're not messing
around i think that goes a long way
these are designed to transition you
from the couch to the gym and from work
into play
giving back is the core though of what
bear bottom does and they've donated
over one thousand
a hundred thousand hundred thousand i
almost only said one thousand a hundred
thousand pairs of shorts to children in
need starting this summer they will be
donating a school lunch for each item
sold they're putting pants on on kids
and putting food in their bellies it's
so awesome so listen right now if you're
listening to this show you can get free
shipping on your first order uh you want
to go to barebottomclothing.com
and use the promo code tastebuds just go
to
bearbottomclothing.com that's bear like
the animal bottom clothing.com and use
the code taste buds to get free shipping
on your first order and to help out the
kids today
knock knock who's there hello hello who
hello friends what is hello fresh pimpy
can you scroll down a sec with
hellofresh you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients and mouth-watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal that's the
that's the big line item we need you to
know when my doorbell goes off a few
things make me more excited than it
going off for food being brought to you
sure that's right and hello fresh is not
only bringing you food they're bringing
you quality food they're bringing you
food that you can cook within the time
that it would have taken you to probably
to make a trip to mcdonald's or
something
and you know it's a great time i know
not look i like to cook personally so
this just makes it even easier for me if
you like to cook they're giving you all
they're getting you off the ground
running here if you're not a cook and
you're not familiar with cooking this is
a way that you can learn how to cook and
be able to cook quite simply and without
being intimidated by the process bit of
an introduction yeah exactly no but if
you're like you know if you're a young
family or a single guy or gal you work
all the time you live alone or you know
you have a big family and you know you
could eliminate going to the supermarket
that's the big thing for me right you'll
have meals actual meals too it's not
just like looking in your fridge and
throwing something together or having
one thing you're gonna have full
thought out pre-measured meals so for me
the thing i like about it the most is
convenience you wanna learn cooking
that's awesome but if you to come home
and have the whole meal laid out and you
just hit the ground running this is the
most convenient option for you it's
great it's great hello freshers family
friendly menu is also a big win for the
back to school season and you get better
value hellofresh is over 30 cheaper than
shopping at the grocery store
you get what we're saying here come on
guys get yourselves together and go get
some hellofresh at hellofresh.com
tastebuds14
and use the promo code tastebuds14
to get
14 free meals including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com tastebuds 14
and use the promo code tastebuds14 and
get up to 14 free meals including free
shipping i love it i use it i think you
will too it's america's number one meal
kit
get it i like i like pickles i like them
a lot i love a bread and butter pickle i
love a nice spear kosher dill like a
stacker on a sandwich i love to crunch
the thing is with the pickles though
there's a ceiling for me i gotta be in
the mood for a pickle number one here we
go and then even after i'm in the mood
for a pickle it's gotta be a good pickle
there's been times i've been in the mood
for a pickle bit in and i'm like oh this
is way too tart way too sour way too
bitter way too a pungent so
the pickle ratio
like i'm not in love with all pickles
it's got to be the right pickle at the
right time and a lot of times
and when a pickle is like floppy and not
crunchy and over saturated you remember
mushy olive there's nothing worse
do you have a mushy olive there are
things worse there's
genocide
that's about it
babe we're talking fried pickles here
which is which is coming into its own as
a staple app in almost everywhere i will
give you that pickles
are good and pickles have a ton in place
and i love a good pickle at the right
time i love a good crunchy pickle i i
love a lot of things about the pickle
all i'm saying is
pickle's not an everyday food
pickle is not in every meal food
pickles um you can't really have more
than like one
it is loaded with sodium to the point
that like olives what
what
do you know how much sodium is in olives
do you know how much sodium is involved
more than pickles
absolutely i i don't know about this
if you it's a good stat to pull up and
if you ate the length of a pickle made
out of olives it would be higher in
sodium i promise you that dude olives
tastes like salt you you go to a deli
and you get one of those deli pickles
that are the size of a goddamn
whale penis
and you slice that up into quarters you
you you can't eat that thing you'll have
to go to the emergency room i just it's
got like seven million grams of sodium
in it
just
put put olives or pickles higher in
sodium
here's the thing too dude you want to
talk about there's no nutritional value
in a pickle as is there's no nutritional
value a cucumber and there's no
nutritional analysis i don't know about
it i don't think there is some good fat
in olives all right i do
let's find out
fermented pickles offer more health
benefits than other pickles all right
but just
pimp just put
olives or pickles higher in sodium
and it
it'll probably come up i think okay
olives are typically high in salt due to
the fact that they are cured and packed
in brine
or salt water
same as the piccolo
it doesn't start all that talks about is
all of sodium we have to know right now
uh scroll back up pim
pimp scroll up
right there olive versus pickled
cucumber in depth nutrition comparison
olive has more iron copper vitamin e and
polyneur what does that taste
fat however pickled cucumber has more
vitamin k and calcium okay so you're
beating me into there daily need
coverage for vitamin k from pickled
cucumber is 38 higher pickled cucumbers
27 times less saturated fat than olive
olive has
1.415 grams of saturated fat while
pickled cucumber only has point zero
five pickles has no fat but that doesn't
mean
but hold on
let's look at the most important part
which is sodium and the pickle takes it
by almost double almost double all right
1208 milligrams of sodium so you can't
eat you can't just pound pickles you you
i don't know what will happen to you but
it won't think i'm not pounding pickles
nah you can't pound pickles and pickles
in ways you don't even know
you can't pound pickles you're
impounding pickles in ways you don't
even know i try to do stuff to pickles
let's talk flav okay you're talking
about the flavor of a pickle being
something you need sparingly it's not an
everyday it's not an everyday food it is
an everyday food for a lot of people
it's an everyday lunch food for a lot of
people for a lot of people olives
definitely never at all at everyday food
now you want to talk flav you go into a
bar you know i've never seen on the bar
pimp
olive backs you know what i've seen
picklebacks a shot where you drink after
it a shot of pickle juice how is that
relevant in this argument of pickles
versus olives because pickle juice
tastes good and people clearly like the
taste of it that they're using it as as
a drink pickles are a cheap food that
have no nutritional value and taste did
you think he's cheaply made you think
he'd go jewish slant like that did you
think he would do that did you think
he'd go jewish slant like that wow dude
wow
a lot of times people can't even finish
the pickle in their plate a lot of times
you go to a diner or a burger people eat
you know the burger or some fries
there's always a couple of bites i have
to pick on some of the pickles left
because a lot of times there's two more
pickles on there there are pickles on
the burger already it's a bit too much
bro olives let's just talk
just the vastness and superiority olives
are a high end food okay here we go this
is it's the same argument every week
this is they're delicious
they have different species i'm a higher
person you are no no but i'm just i mean
come on
you know on oliver's olive is a definite
more a high-end food than a pickle a
pickle is a cucumber that soaked in a
bunch of [ __ ] for a couple of weeks
loaded with sodium and it's a nice
accoutrement but it can't stand alone
you got you think olives can stand a
little more than pickles if you were
castle vetrano if you were green italian
castlevania olives are one of the best
foods on this planet i love
olives in italy i love olives but
there's so many fields and i ate them
like i was eating morsels made by god i
love olives i've said it already i'll
say it again i love olives but i'll tell
you this
sometimes
olive oil babe extra v babe you cook
with it you sprinkle it on everything
olive oil is added to nearly every dish
to make it taste better it's added to
tamponades it's alexa pastas it's added
to salads it's added to fish chicken
olive oil is a staple ingredient olive
oil it's pressed from olives
listen you're you're all right
to break it to you you're off your
argument
olive oil is not olives it's a
derivative of olives and olive oil
tastes nothing like olives
vegetables
canola oil coconut literally like motor
oil oh my god
what's the best oil literally oil on its
own this literally would be its own
sucks i'll give you the best oil there
is olive made oil the best thing
possible
olive oil with popeye
i don't know what i mean that means
i got news for you know what's involved
i get news for you but nice olive oil
cake this is like you the things that
olives is like the olive oil cake sucks
it's oh my god olive oil kids the
hottest shot of menus right now all
across the land because everybody's
afraid to eat anything good anymore
it's delicious by the way i cook with
olive oil all the time it's great to
cook with at a low temp you got to go
higher temps you're going to get you
better get into some grapeseed oil my
friend okay but like this is like if
you're arguing avocados taste good and
then saying avocado oil give me a break
this is got nothing to worry about
bowl of olives assorted both i'll put
every pickle in play i get every olive
in place
glad you brought this up i'll tell you
what it depends on the situation all
right when i go to a bar sometimes
before a set you know
let me finish let me finish let me
finish i go to a bar or comedy club
sometimes right before my set i'm a
little hungry i don't have time to order
food and eat beforehand but i need
something in my stomach i'll go to the
bartender often i'll say combos do me a
favor give me a bunch of olives and a
glass i just got to put something in my
stomach real quick i like it i enjoy it
it's a quick fix i enjoy the flavor
however they had pickles back there
i'd say give me them pickles and i'm
gonna eat them pickles
i'm gonna eat them pickles
pickles have no nutrish i don't know
yeah but babe you can't your mouth is
just gonna suck itself in you can't just
pound sodium spears into your body what
is wrong with you you could have one
pickle i could eat i could eat bread and
butter pickles by the jar delicious
dinner buy the jar i could eat those
okay fine by the jar
later that night baby you would have a
massive baby
dehydrated baby dills by the jar you you
you're going on you go you like the
basis that all pickles are mine is wrong
you got to be in the mood for pickle i
think that i think that is true for
every last person even pickle lovers
the same with olives
who eats 10 pickles a day what psycho
does that
olives do you ever have oh my god you
ever have them at a nice restaurant they
come out of this as an app heated up
with like maybe it's like
maybe some i don't like peppers i do not
like hot olives oh you're wild all right
wow you know what else i love too i love
the process of eating an olive okay i
love it it's a whole dance space
especially
let me guess you shake them around in
your hand as you walk around no yeah but
i love having a beautiful meaty pitted
olive not pitted non-pitted olive i put
it in my mouth it's almost like the
it's almost like the same same
dance as a pistachio you gotta work for
it just a little bit and you take little
pieces at a time then you get the pit
down you start really getting it off the
pit and you yeah you got the pit in your
mouth the pit has a really nice then you
almost choked to death
it's it's fun to eat an olive with a pit
it is everyone has their own tickets i
love that there's a little hole in the
olive i hit it out with everything valve
i love that
every time i love the texture of an
olive i love that it's it has a snap to
it but it's also soft like you know what
i mean it's nothing more satisfying
filling eating an olive oil
i'll take a pitted olive every time and
there's nothing more satisfying than
getting you don't want to hit at all
pull up claws and never pull claus and
pimp please i want to make sure i'm
saying the right plan because i always
mix up cl oh boy
cl
you spelled it wrong but it corrected
you no that's not it see the pickle
c-c-l-a-u
isn't it oh it's c i thought it was a k
i thought it was k
just show me images of cloths and
pickles because i always mix them up
with vlasic yeah clawson's are my
favorites there's nothing scroll down
more that's it i always mix up the brand
name for some reason there's nothing
more satisfying you get a cold jar of
kosher dill cloths and holes at your
supermarket every supermarket has them
uh
not like the highfalutin olive that has
that's the blessing you supermarket with
its presence good luck finding out in
the supermarket and you pull well you
get the jar horseshit that suck and and
who wants that
come on please anyway you just talked
about the olive bar the of bar i'm
saying most supermarkets don't have it
all my local one does oh yeah well
because you're a rich snob that looks
down on people and we've supermarket
established the supermarkets we've
established that we've established that
anyway buckets of olive or for rich
people anyway no that [ __ ] it's it's a
bar
if you go to like fairway over in red
hook they have
like i love 20 gallon buckets of olives
and there's like 10 different ones and
they're in a circle and you go and you
scoop them up i know it's a joke maybe
take a joke you know what i mean what i
can defend myself against your wild
accusations
it was a joke the accusation was a joke
you you you are an odd duck bro why you
are not duck i can't make jokes of
course you can but then you weirdly def
it's weird you're very weird
i'm not crazy i'm weird i'm sitting here
and i'm like this is a weird fellow here
anyway
you claim that olives for an everyday
meal and i'm weird no i said you can't
eat pickles every single day you can eat
olives way more than you could eat pigs
no you can't sell you could have olives
every day wait you can't go every day
huh
you can't have pictures every day you
can't have olives every day watch me so
many people have pickles every day delis
are based on it i own a sandwich
we put pickles on stuff
what does that matter
you know more than anything if you're
dealing with a high quality ingredients
are high quality
favorite sandwich of mine the tuna
what's on that tuna not olives pickles
dill pickle chips okay nobody puts
olives on a sandwich unless you're in
new orleans and you're getting a muffin
that's it and the muffin someone puts it
so a whole culture is dedicated to it
it's one no i'm saying it's one sandwich
i'm saying one sandwich ever ever had
olives on it babe the olive is nice i
mean the pickle is nice as as like the
pickle is like a robin
at best it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's an accoutrement babe
it's not even it's not even it's not
even really thick
bro you really think the cheese garnish
the cheeseburger has olives on it the
pickles on the chick-fil-a sandwich make
the sandwich it's what everybody says
about chick-fil-a it's a garnish deli
sandwiches have pickles on them you go
to a jewish deli there is a array of
pickles brought out to you as a as a
starting place for everything dill
pickles you never watch you know what
pickles are free at diners
do you know why they're free because
they're awesome [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you don't
cost a diner or anything shut up uh i
gotta tell you
sally
sometimes i'm sitting there saying i
want to have a drink
and sometimes i'm sitting there saying
maybe you shouldn't have a drink maybe
you should just take
some vitamins instead or do something
healthy and then sometimes
as of late i've been lucky enough to say
i'll just have a visi
i love it no but not for nothing if
you're looking there's all these
different hard seltzers out there right
now and you want something one of them
to distinguish themselves in the pack
why not grab the one that has vitamins
in it it's great dead serious vitamin c
for that immune system
drinking can run your immune system down
a bit and they got vitamin c right in
the drink to even that out i love it we
just did a beer vs wine app uh and uh
you know i'd like to say that there are
other alternatives and it is the summer
now the warm warm weather is patio
season it's daylight longer sometimes
you want to sip on a refreshing cocktail
sounds like it's not a beer sounds like
the time for a busy watermelon that's
right that's their newest exciting
flavor it's made with real watermelon
juice and it's gonna make those summer
moments even better uh there's also a
new variety pack with four delicious
flavors oh man listen to this blueberry
watermelon kiwi watermelon passion fruit
watermelon and mango watermelon mango
watermelon is my favorite one of all
those uh i love that blueberry
watermelon because that is just a wild
ride on the taste buds guys that's what
we're telling you upgrade your hard
seltzer to visi try it you know there's
there's there's a lot of choices that
they give someone a world see if you
like it
about it because it's got those
antioxidants babes yeah to find out
where you can purchase visit go to
vizzyhardseltzer.com
slash taste buds vizious v-i-z-z-y so
that's vizzy hard seltzer dot com slash
the bud slash taste buds get updates on
the latest flavors uh and more sign up
for their emails at vizi hardseltzer.com
subscribe that's
busyheartselter.com backslash subscribe
you gotta be 21.
i am excited about bespoke posts i don't
even need to look at any of the like the
talking points i just did they help us
with because i got my bespoke box in the
mail i got mine i called each other
because i absolutely loved it i got
things i didn't even ask for me too i
it's a fun like little surprise i loved
it i got a tote bag
i got a knife i got a i got like i think
hydration tablets
i got uh i got all kinds of cool stuff
man
to get started here's what we spoke uh
this summer we spoke post is here to
take your adventure to the next level
with the new line of must-have box of
awesome collections you got to start
over i'm sorry
i put [ __ ] i'm sorry start over i'm
sorry ready what's the matter i i had
that in the shot and it said you can't
do that in the comments
oh really now just let's just start out
let's see i also don't know if i got
hydration tablets
uh this summer bespoke post is here to
take your adventures to the next level
oh my god they are i just got a bespoke
post box in the mail it had so much fun
stuff in it for adventures we called
each other we called each other because
we got our box of awesome that's what uh
bespoke post calls it and they partnered
with all these different businesses to
highlight really quality products that
are of your interest that are like
lifestyle products so i got i got to go
on you go on a box of awesome.com you
take this little quiz and i end up
getting this really cool
really well made like beautiful hunting
knife
yes did you i got um i have a wardrobe i
have a wardrobe bag for like suits and
stuff yes and then they also sent me a
collection of like all these like really
good
like uh really high-end like spf
lotions for the summer i got an
over-the-shoulder tote bag a hunting
knife and whiskey glasses let's have an
adventure wow this is crazy let's go
it's free to sign up you can skip a
month you can cancel any time each box
costs 45 bucks but it has over 70 bucks
worth of stuff yeah exactly and also
you're gonna get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com and then enter the
promo code tastebuds at your checkout
that's box of awesome dot com enter that
promo code taste buds at checkout for 20
off your first box
they're a bunch of you haven't bite into
a pickle that's not like doesn't get
cooked i like those prices
you ever bite into a pickle that's
posing as a pickle but it's still a cuke
that's terrible when the diner brings
them that's the type of pickle i just
bit into a guy
pickle there's an array of dill flavors
which i know because i own a sandwich
shop okay
and it starts with the salty cucumber
flavored one and goes all the way up to
sour did you know that no you didn't
terrific because you don't know no
matter what though you can't eat more
than one of any of them
that's just a lie
more species and varieties of and also
by the way if we're just like brass
taxing it the pickle is not a food that
exists you make a cucumber into a pickle
the olive pulls right off the branch
i want you to eat it all off the branch
you tell me what that tastes like before
i'm just saying it's grown from the
earth it's a natural food it's the
pickle is is it is it it's not edible in
its natural form is it not i have you
ever eaten a raw oh that wasn't it i
should go but there was a lot of good
facts about everything olives are not
edible green or rice yeah there you go
must be treated with lye which you put
on dead bodies to get them to disappear
and cured in a brine or dry salt before
being edible okay but they do come as is
oh come on sal give it up olive branch
is a symbol of peace how about that yeah
olivia newton john how about her pickles
pickles and symbol is a cute way to say
you have a problem on your hands i had a
pickle let's get some of these fun facts
in here real quick and then we'll go to
the maybe we'll go to the polls which
was coined by shakespeare
in a the phrase in a pickle yeah coined
by shakespeare yes
uh while caesar and napoleon thought
they could build muscle
julius caesar and other roman emperors
had soldiers eat the crispy preserves
because they thought they would provide
straight with the that's nothing all
right let's just what's the fun top of
the line top of the line keep going down
pimp because we already did the two word
pickle comes to the netherlands of the
word ladies and gentlemen can i bring
just a side note to your attention about
our wonderful producer the homeless pen
i don't know not only is he not great at
spelling it's come to my attention he
might not know the difference between up
and down
[Laughter]
because often you will say pimp the
control's inverted all right all right
is that what it is yeah the controller
my all right
all right that's good to know pimp cause
many times we sit and we go pimp go down
and it just starts scrolling up very
rapidly i feel like it's a playstation
one game i can't figure out
all right pip we we love you that's good
to know
pickles are stored in outdoor vats it
said babe i have olives as a snack i
have olives as an appetizer i have
olives in my salad i have cooked with
olive oil i i mean i just i mean i'm
telling you right now
i have pickles with my sandwich i have
pickles as a snack i have pickles with
lunch every day what's your eye what
should i drink pickle juice with my
whiskey what's your favorite pickle the
one that you would put
your dill kosher dill i put that up
against a a
uh a bright green castle of toronto
italian olive and i and i got to be
honest with you there's no way you take
that fight there's no way you take that
battle but this is the best you resort
you resign you want to talk about sides
of sandwiches i even go into drinks
pickles i mean the olive even goes it
will go back to the martini that that
did me anything you resort but here's
the thing you resort often to this
argument of if i go seek out freak
cuisine the best version of this one
thing spanish quiz that i can find uh it
beats yours it doesn't it is not a you
have no workhorse what about your brand
you're crazy every single every single
cuisine has their version of the olive
pickle is an american food i'm telling
me you asked me my favorite pickle i
told you you're telling me if you flew
over to italy and got one from the field
workers of this green olive you speak of
that it would beat the pickle sure maybe
it's a better tasting thing in that
moment but my point is is on a
day-to-day basis the greeks have their
olives the spanish people are there the
italians have their all and everybody's
permeated culture
at a level
but those things are staples those those
kalamata all those are staples in the
mediterranean
staples i don't know where you're
getting this they're staples in american
bar food but they don't permeate
different they're staples in jewish
cuisine okay all right there's staples
in southern barbecue pickles and onions
comes with the with the meal every
single time pickles just because it's
not just because it's not as f as as
mediterranean i get it you make a good
point olives you're going to find in
mediterranean cuisine a lot more but
it's a mediterranean food that's an
unfair you'll find it in main dishes too
you'll find it in in in in broth so
you'll find it
you'll find it in uh cacciatore i
understand hunter stew as they used to
call it i understand but my point is not
that my point is is if you want to talk
about a food be more popular
in a certain region because it's a
regional food well who cares i could say
the same thing about pickles the three
countries you're mentioning could fit
inside
america itself through the united states
itself three times over and and
geographically i could just argue that
pickles cover a greater land mass than
the european olive all around is a more
quality food well let's go to the phones
you know let's go to the phone they're
they're they are they are they are a
more quality food it's intense day let's
go to the phones
let's go to the phones i'm not being cut
was that condescending no not at all
well
i get when pip says oh god i get nervous
i just love the the transition to the
phones as always oh all right all right
it sounded like it was like i was maybe
being condescending let me know when a
pickle garden exists
that's true babe yeah that that's what
you want i don't care one of the worst
chains in american history i don't i
don't agree with that when you're there
your family that's for damage for [ __ ]
sure
never tell you i went until i went to
the times square olive garden
and i and i just i was there and i
walked in and i said can i have a table
and i swear to god the lady was like
it's a two-hour wait and i go you treat
family like this
you know what i thought it was the
funniest joke ever got nothing
she's probably hurt it's probably like
one of those things like you think that
was a hack joke no i don't i think it's
a great joke and i would have thought it
was a great joke but i bet you she's
like i've heard it a million yeah yeah
you know the last time i went to the
outer garden i was going upstate to a
very special event that a lot of people
we know we're at okay and i stopped on
my way up there and ate it in olive
garden really yeah why was there food at
the event you were going to
we were getting there late
so we were like we don't know if they're
going to have food so we were we were
hungry and we were like it mean justin
silver and josh admirer stopped at an
olive garden and i got to tell you and
you sat down on your way to the event
and had a meal we got we we ran we ran
the apps menu as you like to say and we
just had we got the bottomless salad and
then we just started running that you
know what that is actually pretty damn
good you know what what the key
ingredient is canola oil yeah the uh
if you think they're using mass olive
oil in the olive garden you're out of
you're out of your mind i mean olives at
olive garden should be expected and in
that and in that salad they're using
olives i do not think they do there's
some pepperonis in there but they put
all of those they put all this all right
she wouldn't if she saw could they not
you're going to serve a garden salad at
the olive garden with no olives if you
see someone standing on eating a pickle
you would say look at this distinguished
individual eating a nice refreshing deli
snack if she's the one eating olives by
themselves that person is not okay that
is his sheer side of it that's so nice
right you know when someone tries to
make a point but it doesn't hit
when i see someone alone can you scroll
up him if i see someone alone eating a
pickle i don't go look at this
distinguished joke
he's trying to be funny
i know joe and i'm trying to be funny on
the heels of him he's a guy trying to be
funny why are you attacking you can't
now make comments on this when we go to
the following you can make comments why
are you defending why you keep telling
me that things are a joke when i'm in
the middle of trying to make a joke you
go you go when i see a man's eating a
pickle i would never say he's
continually tried to make a joke but he
did not write something that was true it
doesn't resonate you don't when you see
someone standing alone eating a pickle
you don't go look at this
individual eating refreshing
that if you're eating raisinets at the
movie theater it's because you're
getting you're
ducked by a poor or whatever that guy
wrote that we love to comment but it was
still a funny comment
how did i
i don't remember it all right anyway
uh juicy pickle or
juicy soggy nut like wannabe raisins
pickles babe when they when they bring
up dirty martini i show them this and
that's a picture of pickles in the
martini you don't get a side of olives
when you order from a sub-sandwich shop
now do you care about that
you're going against a titan of lunch
time dude i absolutely love kosher dill
pickles with all my heart but those gr
big green uh bar olive god damn it those
great
bar olives stuffed with blue cheese or
ever had the purple greeks with the feta
cheese come on choose olives
but almost begrudgingly um i don't like
the i love stuffed olives i don't i like
the garlic stuffed ones i don't like the
cheese stuffed ones
if you distill the emotion if you
distill uh the emotion of hate and then
boil it down to a syrup you get olives
that's great
you always hear about pickles i'm gonna
pickle here also the family in rugrats
last name was pickles i didn't know that
so pickles for the win pickles hands
down oh this looks like it's gonna be a
routine start it hold on that started as
a as almost like a seinfeldian
but then he didn't follow yeah well it's
just a joke joe
[Laughter]
he was trying to make a joke
is this show damaging payroll it didn't
pay off is this show damage tell
yourself look in the mirror and tell
yourself the same thing you just told me
is this show damaging our friendship
olives grow naturally from [ __ ]
olives grow naturally is that a yes
grow naturally from mother earth olives
grow naturally from mother earth pickles
are the estranged uncle who has an
obsession with vinegar and being in
everyone's business can't wait to hear
joe say can i finish my point
and then proceed to say absolutely
nothing that resembles a point knowing
him he probably picked olives too jordan
you lost me on the last sentence
salon is manic like debating style could
never make olives more appealing than
pickles thank you for always being the
voice of regent joe
perfect tweet alex
oh i'm going to get
water sad taste in your mouth oh i am
going to get with like with joey's
slaughtered his all-encompassing
umbrella remarks owls are horrible i
don't like pickles either but pickles
have never been hidden
meatball and baby
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
this poor guy threw up at a new year's
eve party because he bit a meatball with
an olive in it
that's the winner man that's all the
eagle meister you were drinking sam oh
my god i got lighted
s-a-m-a-t-t-o-x
47. that's right
should we was i talking over it wait
read it again sal cause i was talking
over it i want to make sure you get his
handle clear sorry
he said uh
there he is
olives are horrible i don't like pickles
either but pickles have never been
hidden inside a meatball and made me
vomit at a new year's party
all right sam yeah just read his handle
again
sam maddox47 at s a m a t t o x four
seven yeah i was just saying i was i was
like talking while you're reading his
hand you got like
no probably uh i
i mean i can tell we gotta we're closing
in on eighteen thousand votes if you
were fresh pimp i think you might
we're closing in on 18 000 votes if this
this is going to be bad man i'm going on
a slide
you know what i should have learned from
the martini with the olives in it that
people just don't like them this is
going to be one of those big big big big
big big differences you do remember the
moment in which i said to you there's
nothing i love more than an olive bar
i'll take olives and you said i gotta
have olives baby because i think
and i said i got a sandwich i can gladly
defend pickles i said pickles are
probably the favorite i said pickles are
probably the favorite but i gotta defend
what i think is better yeah and i think
i like pickles but i'm choosing one you
can only choose one it's like island no
i understand i understand i got to pick
up what was your eric snowden moment and
was it worth it
i will tell you right now i'm noticing
that
though
the less
distinguished foods always come out on
top
i mean
pickles argument is oldest time you just
don't get my food
you just don't get it it's above your
head i get it it's i have a more
advanced palette shut down
it's not true it's just
it's just it's just a cute it's just a
brush
hit a refresh
and then show us
i don't even want to see it i don't want
to see it
amen
god damn it
i can't take these routings anymore read
the numbers for the audience
76.8 percent pickles to 23.2
you beat me by three times
i still love you babe i love you too
thank you for subscribing keep
subscribing keep following us keep
sharing the show we love you guys as
much
on itunes
follow us on spotify please tell someone
about us that's the only way we could
grow you guys are loving it tell someone
else we always forget to ask you that
don't forget to listen to the audio
we're getting so many great video hits
and we're getting a lot of nice audio
hits too but listen to the audio
download the podcast yeah you know maybe
maybe you go on a jog or something like
that
uh this was great at joe derosa comedy
on twitter and instagram
at savolcano on all the socials uh to
tenderloins.com tour for our tickets on
sale now we're coming to come to your
city taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds